Emmy Grammy and Golden Globe
award-winning millionaire actor comedian
writer director producer singer
songwriter rapper and DJ Donald Glover
also known as childish gambino has a new
song out about how terrible America is
what incredible luck taani he's e-coat
slams Kanye West for pushing white
freedom and a lying with slaveholders
just a week after TMZ producer Van
Lathan slams Kanye for morphing into
something that is not real they must
have been lucky to to be so successful
but who's really keeping it real in 2018
what is real what is really really real
then there's a lot in the news I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
what luck those guys have been so
successful for such a terrible place
that just keeps people who look like
them down what a what incredible luck we
will analyze that we will also analyze
the modern day minstrel show before we
get 20 of that I have to thank a sponsor
of ours a really good sponsor which I am
about to start using myself called a
candid ko candid company and so they
these guys will fix your mouth so if you
have a crooked crooked tooth crowded
teeth gaps between your teeth etc when I
was a kid I had braces just like a lot
of kids did you know and they're so
expensive they're just awful you got to
go into the orthodontist all this stuff
no one wants to wear them as an adult
there are some other solutions for this
clear aligners that require you to go to
the orthodontists office they're also
super expensive luckily we have
discovered this great company called
candid candid is helping people gain
confidence through accessible and
affordable orthodontic care there
actually are some things in my teeth
that I have to fix so it's very excited
to get candid as a sponsor because
obviously you know Ben hasn't paid me in
months and months so all I get are these
sponsors and they're really good I can't
wait to start the treatment candid makes
the process of straightening your teeth
convenient and easy by having the
customer take the process into their own
hands
straighter and brighter teeth and an
average of six months costs sixty-five
percent less than braces no office
visits needed everything delivered to
your home White Glove customer service
email phone support candid we'll set up
a video call with you to answer any
questions you have throughout the
process only uses orthodontists while
other aligner companies use dentists or
dental professionals they use
orthodontists here the aligners fix
crooked teeth crowding protrusion gaps
they're all tailored to your specific
case you'll get a 3d preview of what
your treatment will look like you're one
step away from getting straighter whiter
teeth like little ole me take advantage
of candids risk free modeling kit
guarantee plus when you use my dedicated
link candid co.com /co fac OVF EF e
you'll save $25 on your model over 25
percent rather on your modeling kit 25%
that's breath good as an important
distinction that is candid co.com
/ cough FAC OVF EF
to get 25% off the price of your
modeling kit candid co.com slash coffe
FA Co V Fe Fe okay childish gambino has
this new song and it is being hailed
mostly by white liberals as a great work
of genius the the guy opens up and if
you don't know childish gambino that's
the alter ego of donald glover he's a TV
writer he's won Emmys he's really
talented guy and so this is the guy who
opened up his song redbone with the
words but stay woke
just to give you an idea of his politics
there's new song is called this is
America and Democrats love it because
this song it's supposed to be a searing
indictment of the US and the Second
Amendment and police brutality and I
don't know whatever other lefty things
you want to throw in there America is
the worst place ever man do Democrats
love it and this the reason it's
interesting culturally the reason we
have to talk about it and everyone is
missing what they should be taking away
is the point of this song is it supposed
to be in part a satire of old minstrel
shows shows of black men you know
mocking black men and all of this in
reality this type of entertainment is
the modern-day minstrel show we'll get
to that later first let's take a look at
the video
[Music]
I got just living on got you're slipping
[Music]
[Music]
you get the idea so for those who
couldn't see for those who were just
listening Donald Glover comes on in and
he's dancing and it's all fun and happy
that's a nice little beat you know and
then he goes up to a hooded guy and just
pulls out a gun and blasts him right in
the head and he comes in there's a nice
black choir singing and they're in sort
of regalia and it's all nice and happy
Donald Glover comes in dancing and then
just mows them all down with an ak-47
and this and this is America right there
singing all this nice stuff and then
when you start shooting people this is
America that's what they're saying it's
searing indictment comes in cars on fire
in the background gang crime and it just
reminds you of Democrat run cities
that's what it'll look at this is
supposed to be this is America this is
Democrat run cities it's supposed to
look like Detroit all of the cars you
know on fire being broken down the last
time a Republican ran Detroit Pericles
was running Athens but listen to the
lyrics so if for those who couldn't make
out quite what's being said I think you
could it's just the lyrics are awful the
lyrics begin this is the this is the
first stanza yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah go go away yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah go go away not
exactly Shelly or John Keats or anything
not even you know Isaiah Berlin that
this is the lyrical content but we'll
get to we'll get to why this is terrible
artwork later first let's just talk
about the politics so it opens up we
just want a party party just for you we
just want the money money just for you I
know you want a party party just for me
yes this is America guns in my area I
got the strap I got a carry-on and by
the way what you should say is I get to
carry them because in all of the other
countries in the world when there are
guns and knives in their area you don't
get to carry them and then you get
killed and you don't get to protect
yourself the lyrics goes on America I
just checked my following list and you
go tell somebody you mother
eva's Oh me so before we go on here that
that's
crucial part you owe me things are
terrible people are getting shot
everything's bad all of the nice things
all of the nice dancing that's just a
facade and really we're just getting
gunned down there's there is actually
one interesting political line he says
here which is this is a celli that's a
tool and what he's referring to is this
is a cell phone and there have been
instances of black men being shot dead
because they pull out a cell phone and
the cops think it's a gun and it's a
tense situation and it's the
difference.we guns and cell phones right
guns are a tool cell phones are a tool
because they can actually protect
against overreach by the government the
whole song is just terrible political
commentary it is but it's importantly
it's just political commentary without
the political terror commentary the
phone is there the sergeant the phone
the song is dreadful it's not good art
even with the political commentary it's
not very good but this is the evidence
of a bad work of art if the work of art
only stands on its politics it isn't
good art it's it's why it's what
comedians have to do it's why Jimmy
Kimmel has to just give political
monologues and cries cuz he's not
telling he can't tell good jokes so it's
a crutch but why the crazy dance why is
Donald Webber doing this crazy dance one
of the theories suggested here is he's
doing exaggerated poses like in minstrel
shows like in the Jim Crow South there
the lyric he says his grandma told me
get your money black man get your money
go out there and get your money and what
critics are suggesting is this is a
little bit of a distraction so you're
not seeing all the bad stuff that's
going on in the background
he's showing how we get distracted by
popular entertainment and we get
distracted by modern minstrel shows and
that this is supposed to be a satire of
a minstrel show all of the big crazy
faces all of the wild dancing and
happy-go-lucky singing and jumping
around we'll get back to that because
that's the whole key race hustlers from
Hollywood to New York from these music
videos to the pages of the Atlantic they
are providing the new minstrel show it's
the same old audience of white Democrats
but it's the new minstrel show all of
that later first keeping it real kanye
West is extolling the virtues of free
thought and speaking his mind and
according to TMZ producer van Latham
that is most certainly not keeping it
real if you say what you think and
you're
explaining the world as you see it that
is not keeping it real but then if you
just do automatically what other people
tell you to do even if it's not a true
narrative that is keeping it real I
understand why you're confused keeping
it real is another leftist euphemism I I
did this Praeger video that's gotten a
lot of play from last week and it's
about how the left morphs language
transforms and perverts language to mean
the opposite of what it says it means
keeping it real is a great example of
this because keeping it real is the
opposite of what it said keeping it real
is really keeping it unreal Vann Lathan
said I'm disappointed I'm appalled and
brother I'm unbelievably hurt by the
fact that to me you Kanye West have
morphed into something that is not real
what is real Chris Rock the comedian
Chris Rock gives some guidance on what
real is then not no one to answer to
your question Oh keeping it real
let's keep it real
[Applause]
keeping it real keeping it dumb that's
what it is Chris Rock this is a good
example of you know funny because it's
true the people are laughing at this
because it is true and Chris Rock is
really good at this kind of social
commentary is he's using this expression
this leftist euphemism which is
primarily a stereotype of a black saying
keeping it real and he's saying what
keeping it real means it's not keeping
it real means keeping it dumb it means
you know this being proud to say no I
don't want education no I don't want to
better myself I don't I don't want to
better my circumstances in my family
life in my personal life I want to keep
it real as if to save reality is the
opposite of improvement and keeping it
real keeping it dumb brings us to time
the easy coats who is trending on
Twitter last time I checked ton easy
coats is every white liberals favorite
magazine writer all of your is pseudo
sophistic at white liberal friends will
love tan easy coats and I'll explain why
in a minute
taani easy coats is the MacArthur Genius
grant winner National Book Award winner
he's won a ton of awards he just wrote a
piece attacking Kanye West for speaking
his mind and embracing Donald Trump the
title of that piece is I'm not black I'm
Kanye I'm not black I'm Kanye what he's
referring to is the old expression from
OJ Simpson I'm not black I'm og oj
saying i transcend my race i'm not just
gonna be ghettoized into this one a
particular characteristic and
demographic you want to put me in I'm
bigger than that so just from the title
now we note on easy codes is comparing
Kanye to a wife-beating double murderer
the piece only gets worse from here
Donaghy zico's opens up using these
phrases like the yawning whiteness this
is why white liberals love it so much
you say oh yes we are boring yes we do
or we're yawning yes keep keep talking
yeah that's right
of course you couldn't use that phrase
about any other racial group or ethnic
group you couldn't talk about the the
bellowing Italian miss or something you
know you can you bet but you can use it
went on easy coach uses in the Atlantic
this oh yes well how brave has from so
then tan easy coats compares Kanye West
and Michael Jackson the the black God
dying to be white you know because
Michael Jackson bleached his skin so
first
this is within a few paragraphs kanye
west compared town easy codes compares
kanye west to a double murderer
wife-beater and then he compares him to
a child molesting drug addict but this
is that this is the great erudite
serious thinker she opens up with these
two outrageous comparisons codes then
makes a series of stupid points and I
think he's being obtuse here because
he's either being obtuse or he is
genuinely dumb and I don't think he's
genuinely dumb I tend to think it's the
former so Coates takes issue that Kanye
said that Donald Trump not Barack Obama
proof that Kanye could be president
Kanye said this he said yeah when Donald
Trump became president I realized I
could become president this is obviously
true but all time he's e-coat ceases
color.all ton easy coatsy's is Oh Barack
Obama's black and Kanye is black that
should be the inspiration but what Kanye
West is seeing is Barack Obama is this
harvard-educated lawyer political
activist guy and Donald Trump is a
pop-culture figure I'm a pop-culture
figure I'm not a lawyer I'm not a
political activist I'm just a pop
culture guy if the big outrageous pop
culture guy can become president so can
i that is the much truer comparison but
all coatsy's his color and all he writes
about his color so coats then takes
issue with Kanye West calling Chicago
the murder capital of the world so last
year Chicago had a fifty nine point four
percent increase in murders over 2015
this is the highest level of murders
since the mid 1990s which was a huge
high in gun murders Chicago has this
shocking number of murders but ton easy
Coates wants to point out the rate the
per capita of murder rate is lower than
st. Louis and Detroit and a few other
terrible cities so you know Kanye lied
so what Kanye said is not true because
you know Chicago has some really nice
neighborhoods so that brings down the
per capita murder rate you know there's
a lot of business that happens there so
Brees dead so so what Kanye West said is
not true this is totally dishonest
criticism is that or is that really what
you're saying you're saying Chicago had
a 59% increase in the murder rate more
than one person on average can die every
day and be murdered every day in Chicago
but oh you call it the murder capital of
the world it's really only the third
murder case
it'll obviously by the way when you call
something a murder capital of the world
in America
you're obviously speaking hyperbolically
isn't but people it's not like people
don't know that Fallujah exists that
these two awful war-torn cities Raqqa
exists cities there they're at war in
the Middle East no one's suggesting that
those places aren't awful and don't have
higher murder rates you're speaking
hyperbolically obviously Chicago has a
very high murder rate and Kanye West
made the right criticism he said Barack
Obama came up on race hustling he's from
Chicago and Chicago didn't improve it
got worse during his tenure maybe that
says something about his policies so
totally dishonest from coats coats then
criticizes West very telling Lee because
West never fell into the bitterness of
his peers
that's a quote he never grew up and
became bitter the criticisms that he
never got bitter that he didn't you
Kanye you you'd never decided to start
dividing and falling into a victimhood
and aggrievement culture even though
Kanye by the way because you haven't
done that you've succeeded beyond your
wildest dreams Coates becomes hysterical
at this point he then says Michael
Jackson endorsed the destruction of all
black people that's actually a claim in
this absurd Atlantic article and then
Coates concludes quote and so for Kanye
West I wonder what he might be if he
could find himself back into connection
back to that place where he sought not a
disconnected freedom of eye but a black
freedom that called him back back to the
bone and drum back to Chicago back to
home if a white writer had written this
article he would be run out of town on a
rail for it's absurd blatant racism
because what would Coates is saying to
West is come back he said literally says
come back to the bone and drum come back
to your inescapable immutable irrational
racial roots come back keep it parochial
keep it divided keep it tribal keep it
bitter keep it real that's what he's
saying what is real what is real what
would it mean to really keep it real to
keep it really really real taani easy
Coates has won the Hillman prize the
National Magazine Award the George Polk
award the Harriet Beecher Stowe award
the
American Library Fellowship American
Library in Paris fellowship the National
Book Award and the MacArthur Genius
grant probably the most sought-after
award in the world what about Donald
Glover childish gambino Donald Glover
has won multiple Emmy Awards a Grammy
Critics Choice Award multiple Writers
Guild Awards and the the n-double-a-cp
award the list goes on and on
multi-millionaire I think at last check
he's got well over 12 million dollars
what what do they have in common one of
these two guys have in common
they push a grievance narrative to a
largely white audience they push this
narrative that blacks are necessarily
kept down they can't succeed hard work
won't cut it got to keep it divided got
to keep it real stop pretending that you
can make it in America Kayne shut up
stop saying that people can make it in
America if they just better themselves
and educate themselves and follow
certain social mores that will ensure
success for their children or make it
far more likely that their children will
succeed and that they will succeed
simple social mores that are open to
everybody stop telling them that tell
them that they can't succeed that they
gotta stay down and yet ironically
Donald Glover and tana hazy coats are
proof in themselves
that this narrative isn't true how many
awards have they won how many millions
of dollars have they made combined what
social and cultural influence do they
have combined and but then they don't
preach what they practice because the
narrative sells they're their own lives
their testament that doesn't sell the
Kanye true narrative doesn't sell but
that this narrative sells this is the
modern minstrel show yeah that's what it
is the critics are calling this this
donald glover video an assault on
minstrel shows it is in reality is the
complete opposite it is the modern
minstrel show for those who don't know
what a minstrel show is for you know the
sixteen year olds in the audience who
didn't you haven't studied this or seen
this in the old days minstrel shows
portrayed black people as inept and
frivolous and unable to better
themselves here's an example of one
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends it is indeed a financial
pleasure to have so many of you resemble
here today on this auspicious occasion
see so it's the white person puts on the
black face and the big white lips and
then mispronounces words so says
resemble instead of a symbol and
suspicious instead of auspicious haha'
he's a dimwit who can't really better
himself and hahaha and then the white
audience laughs and the white audience
applauds and this didn't just exist in
the 19th century in the early 20th this
happened in the 70s a little bit to
television shows like good times come to
mind good times was created by white
lefties shows created by Norman Lee or
that kind of thing and they pretend that
they're attacking problems in some ways
they're offering social commentary but
it's also the same effect you know you
have the the wild crazy black character
saying the catchphrase and then although
mostly white liberal audience laughs and
applauds so what is the minstrel show
today because at the time they didn't
realize that that those were modern-day
minstrel shows in the 1970s what's their
minstrel show today the left is totally
delusional they're looking for another
amos and andy they're looking for this
with the big black face and the big
white lips and everything the modern-day
minstrel show doesn't look like that
modern-day minstrel show on the pages of
the atlantic and in music videos portray
precisely the same thing though don't
they they they they're the old minstrel
shows played primarily to white Democrat
audience the the new minstrel shows
precisely the same audience they play to
exactly the same group of people
Kanye West is rejecting that ridiculous
a narrative that he and and Glover and
Coates proved by their very lives and
careers is untrue so one of the race
hustlers do what what do these guys do
they they do the same thing that they
did to Candace Owens and Thomas Sol and
des Clarence Thomas to every other black
person who has ever had the temerity the
abject audacity to question the
enfeebling Democrat narrative of
grievance they pilloried them as Uncle
Tom's that's all they ever heard Uncle
Tom's there in authentically black their
race traders they're the worst kind of
evil they say how dare you speak for
yourself how dare we have a narrative
here's the script here's the script you
have to
your we gave you the script you have I
listen I know that I've won the
MacArthur Genius award and I've
succeeded beyond my wildest dreams
because this is the land of opportunity
and obviously if you work hard over
enough time you can better yourself
that's not the script you got it here
take the script and dance play your part
and dance that's what they tell them to
do and it's despicable and by the way it
shows what courage it takes to
contradict that entrenched prevailing
interest that's been around for a very
long time what courage it takes for a
guy like Kanye West we kind of joke
about him because Kanye West as an
eccentric crazy character takes a lot of
guts to do what he did
takes a lot of guts for that guy to
tweet out Thomas soul quotes and to say
I like Candace Owens and to say I enjoy
listening to Jordan Peterson takes a lot
of guts because then he'll be a cute
because of what the minute he describes
reality as it really is as he sees it
let's say now you're not keeping it real
you're gonna have dare you have we're
gonna come after you were gonna pillory
you and it isn't it isn't just racial
issues that you see this on because
conservatives should be pretty careful
here that there are actually racial
issues in the country we like to say
there aren't racial issues at all but
then obviously we know that there are
racial issues in the United States there
are different rates of earning different
rates of marriage out of wedlock birth
abortion crime education it the majority
of black babies in New York City are
aborted rather than born that is a major
racial issue and you can't you can't
blame all of that on the legacy of
slavery that's what the left wants to do
they say oh it's all the legacy of
slavery it's all that you can't blame it
all on that you can you can import blame
it on the legacy of Democrats in the
Great Society you can import blame it on
the good intentions policies of
affirmative action and the good
intentions allegedly policies of the
Great Society you can import blame it on
exclusion you can import blame it on a
legacy of division but they're clearly
regardless of if you're gonna blame it
on historical ills or modern policies or
Democrats or mostly just Democrats I
guess you would blame it on clearly
there are issues there's no question
about that and I've never really liked
sometimes on the right we see this issue
so clearly and then we really want to
explain it so we use that the Democrat
plantation language we say the Democrats
are keeping blacks on the planet
because it's evocative language I don't
really like that I find it kind of
condescending I know I just I don't
think it achieves anything
I think people listen to say are you
kidding me who are you to tell me but we
shouldn't be reactionary that plays into
the left hands too and and the speaking
of the left hand the minstrel see the
minstrel show of keeping it real extends
way beyond a rapper and an essayist it
extends way beyond Donald Glover and
Tana hazy coats it is all over the place
it is all over the Academy the
university is the mainstream media it's
everywhere it is beyond racial issues
40% of colleges have no Republican
professors 40% have none it's not to say
60% of professors are Democrats 40% of
colleges have no Republican professors
that's according to a National
Association of scholars article they
lack even one Republican professor
Mitchell Lambert is an associate
professor of Business at Brooklyn
College shows that seventy eight point
two percent of academic departments
sampled had zero Republicans or so few
quote as to make no difference so what
happens in that case what happens when
your college has not a single person who
contradicts the politically correct
perspective well then you don't get any
perspective you don't get any other
ideas it's a it's a ghettoizing
experience this is an example of that
euphemism how keeping it real is the
opposite of real it is the opposite the
university is the opposite of that the
how the the place that is supposed to
promote intellectual curiosity and
freedom and the relentless pursuit of
truth it does the opposite of that the
same is true of the mainstream media
after the 2016 election the executive
editor of the New York Times Dean Baquet
said quote if I have a mayor Copa for
journalists and journalism it's that
we've got to do a much better job of
being on the road out in the country
talking to different kinds of people
than we talk to especially if you happen
to be in New York based news
organization and remind ourselves that
New York is not the real world and that
is true I can I tell I can promise you
that having spent a lot of time in New
York it's not the real world
there's a new study in the journal
of expertise I have to say how many of
these journals are there they have all
of these geminus started like the
Journal of cough FA or something they
have the Journal of this in the Journal
of that I don't know how reliable they
are but the Journal of expertise shows a
majority of staff writers and editors at
the New York Times in the Wall Street
Journal come from elite universities
Harvard Yale Princeton all the you know
you know where they they have a measure
based on median SAT score or something
52 percent of times staff writers and
editors 54% of Wall Street Journal staff
writers and editors now you might say
well those are prestigious places it's
not surprising that they come from
prestigious universities this actually
is a fairly new thing net that the the
journalism that reporting the news is
for the elites the very very highly
educated and specifically educated in
the old days the elite grads they
wouldn't go to The Wall Street Journal
they would go to Wall Street and make a
ton of money or they would go to
industry and make a ton of money they
would they wouldn't go to report the
news newspaper reporting was more of a
trade it was a specialty you had to have
a relentless dogged pursuit of a story
you had it was sort of something wrong
with you same thing with artists you
know there had to be something wrong
with you to say well I I don't want to
make a lot of money I want to put myself
in a lot of danger I want to work really
really hard but I want to pursue the
truth I want to pursue these stories
it wasn't reporting was it really meant
for these big ego elite types because
those guys they want to prescribe or
proscribe rather than describe what
they're seeing they want to give their
commentary they want to offer what they
think the society should look like or
why it's looking this way rather than
just reporting the events as they see
them and in part it's because to
actually do good investigative reporting
is very hard and very hard work and you
don't get a lot of accolades and glamour
for it so all of the big ego people they
want to prescribe you know they've
they've read through Sidda T's so they
want they say oh I can explain this to
you and by the way that's what we're
seeing now and all of these places that
used to do a good investigative work
we're now seeing a proliferation of
commentary masquerading is reporting
there's what is real what's really real
like well this is it's the commentary of
these people but is it their reporting
this is why they get it so so wrong
because look on this show at the daily
wire on the bench Bureau show the Andrew
Clavin show whatever Matt Walsh show we
say this is commentary this is our
perspective this is cultural commentary
New York Times doesn't do that the New
York Times says this is the news but
they give exactly the same amount of
commentary the exact amount of political
opinion as any other commentary network
does they say but these are the facts
CNN just the facts the Washington Post
democracy dies in darkness just the
facts I'm a banana but that's nonsense
which is why they're dishonest which is
why they're fake news and that's why
they get it so wrong it creates a
totally parochial point of view that has
delusions of cosmopolitanism or or
universality or any of this but they're
not they come from the same little
schools that come from the same little
cities they go to the same little dinner
clubs they read the same Tommy Z coats
essay they give it the same applause the
left is right about one thing they don't
know that they're right but they're
right about one thing
bigotry is insidious it's very hard to
detect they're right about that they're
not detecting it you know they're
certainly not they talk about the
unconscious biases they yeah they're not
conscious of them because they are
demanding the left demands and pushes a
false narrative that blacks specifically
but racial minorities more broadly
cannot succeed they just can't they're
just inept they're just as inept and
helpless as the minstrel shows of the
days gone by never mind that this
narrative is demonstrably false that's
what the audience demands that's what
the Atlantic audience demands and very
sadly performers of this false narrative
are gonna dance to the same old tune
they're doing it now and it's trending
ontwitter
and they're gonna win more awards for it
and they're gonna keep they're gonna
make even more ridiculous claims in that
same old audiences because oh oh oh
that's right you can't better yourself
oh it's really really sad and maybe
people will someday be able to see
through the insidiousness of that that
bigotry but probably not anytime soon
okay enough about race do we haven't a
little bit of time so I'm glad I'm glad
before we had to cut to break that we
were able to get to Kanye watch for the
17th day in a row I think this show is
basically going to be renamed the Kanye
West program
kanye west's analysis we got to get to
the news before we get to the news I'm
sorry I'm sorry I have to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube we got so much to
talk about I want to talk about Rosie
O'Donnell going to the clink throwing
Rosie O'Donnell behind bars hopefully I
want to talk about John McCain a little
bit and John McCain it look it appears
that he's in the last days it looks like
he's dying of aggressive brain cancer
but he ain't going out without a fight
and he's hitting a lot of former allies
so we'll talk about that but if you're
not on daily wire.com I got to say
goodbye to you if you are there thank
you very much you always keep the lights
on you keep khofifah in my cup go over
there right now you get it's $10 a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
at the end work laven show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh
show that is you can check out now if
you if you ever thought you know Pablo
is not Catholic enough for me then you
can then you can watch the Matt Walsh
show and you it gets your fill so I go
over there right now you'll get to ask
questions in the conversation that's
coming up next one up is little ol me so
you're gonna ask the questions everybody
can watch only subscribers can ask
questions many are called for you were
chosen but that doesn't matter
mmm hold on just got to keep it real a
little bit over here I'm gonna kid oh
those are real that is keeping it real
those are the Kanye West vintage leftist
tears they have been pouring in as
Hawaii spews lava so to the continental
United States has been spewing leftist
tears ever since Kanye West said that he
liked Donald Trump and those are real
that is it's hard to tell keeping it
real from real these days that is oh wow
go over I'm gonna take a few gulps
myself go to daily wire.com you'll get
the leftist ears tumblr we'll be right
back with the news
dee-lish so let's get to a really happy
news story Rosie O'Donnell is in trouble
with the law if justice is blind Rosie
O'Donnell may now be headed to the clink
we are joined for comment by President
Donald Trump mr. president your reaction
I like to see bad people fail
Rosie failed I'm happy about it she's
basically a disaster well she called me
a snake oil salesman and you know coming
from Rosie that's pretty low because
when you look at her and when you see
the mind the mind is is weak I don't see
it I don't get it I never understood how
does she even get on television I
believe Barbara made a terrible mistake
putting a run and I think Barbara's
probably paying a big price when you see
the mind you know you're totally right
mr. president the mind is weak the -
wait so Rosie apparently made illegal
campaign donations on five separate
occasions and when you donate to a
political candidate there was a limit
for campaign donations in this case I
believe the limits $2,700 and Rosie XT
exceeded it apparently vastly exceeded
it so you might recall you're having
deja vu all over again
dinesh d'souza the conservative
filmmaker and columnist he did this - he
did this exact same thing for his friend
Wendy long and I was working races in
New York when Wendy long was running in
this race
Wendy long was his old pal from
Dartmouth she was never gonna win this
Senate seat in New York and he donated
$20,000 to her instead of the legal
limit so he donated over the limit one
certainly not enough money to make any
difference in politics and to a race
that was unwinnable it just wasn't gonna
happen
for this great crime dinesh for giving a
little extra money to his old college
pal in a race that was never gonna win
he was sentenced to five years probation
eight months in a halfway house and a
thirty thousand dollar fine
the reason that Dinesh got this usually
these cases aren't prosecuted the reason
that he was prosecuted and sent to the
clink is because he was a major critic
of Barack Obama he made these films
against Barack Obama he was a relentless
critic of Obama so he was selectively
prosecuted and sentenced to absurd
time for this this minor first time
offense Rosie O'Donnell has donated way
more money than that to many more
candidates apparently $90,000 in just
this cycle alone and then when she was
called out on it she claimed ignorance
she said well I didn't know what there
was a limit I didn't know what the limit
was the mind the mind it's just not
there as Donald Trump says the mind is
not so she said I didn't know how was I
supposed to know I mean I know it's the
law and it's written on every campaign
website and it's actually by law clearly
spelled out but you know if it was too
much the candidates should return the
money but as you might know ignorant of
the law is no excuse that's not an
excuse not to be prosecuted so will she
be prosecuted I don't know usually the
first time offenders don't get
prosecuted
Rosie is clearly a multiple time
offender here is justice blind are they
gonna go after Rosie it's funny because
last time Obama was in office and Obama
hated dinesh and now at Trump is in
office and Donald Trump is Rosie
O'Donnell's primary antagonist in the
entire world there was that time during
the Ted will point out Rosie started the
fight
but that during the debate megyn kelly
said Donald Trump you have called women
slobs and pigs and idiots and this and
then and the interrupted he said only
Rosie O'Donnell oh so who knows it's
just as blind there are two points on
this that you should think about one is
justice under the law if it's good for
dinesh it's got to be good for Rosie
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander also we should think about
the justice of the law these these are
limits on campaign contributions I think
this is a terrible law I think it's
anti-constitutional I don't think we
should have these sort of limits on how
much you can give to a political
candidate because one it's
anti-constitutional it suppresses your
your political speech we know that money
is speech if I it costs money to make a
big yard sign it costs money to to write
an op-ed it costs money to publish
things it costs it speech can require
money and your speech will reach a
certain number of people depending on
how much money you spend we know that in
the Citizens United case speech was we
know that people don't lose their
constitutional rights to free speech
just because they organize in groups so
I find all of these
campaign finance laws
anti-constitutional but it also it
doesn't achieve what it wants to achieve
it just creates shady backroom ways for
the money to transfer big politics is
always going to attract big money this
is an argument for small government if
you don't want big money in politics
don't have big politics have small
government but also the minute you start
limiting donating to a campaign or
donating it to this then you're gonna
have more money going to the party
structures that's going to give more
corruption for the party bosses to pick
winners and losers you're going to have
super PACs which are apparently shady or
the Democrats hate super PACs you're
just gonna put the money there and this
brings us to john mccain john mccain is
the big proponent of campaign donation
limits john mccain his major campaign
law campaign mccain feingold
was struck down in the citizens united
decision the famous citizens united
decision that said that people don't
give up their rights when they
organizing groups mccain was very angry
about that decision this was one of his
landmark pieces of legislation now john
mccain is dying and it looks like he's
in his last days so people are gonna not
criticize him they're not going to
attack him because the you don't want to
attack a dying man which is perfectly
right it is distasteful to unnecessarily
speak ill of the dead and the dying but
in the last few minutes here i would
like to point out john mccain seems to
be taking advantage of this of this
social more a because he's not going
peacefully he is not saying i just you
know want to spend my last days just
only talking about the nice things and
enjoying my impressive life he's
launching a memoir he's a he just leaked
that he doesn't want donald trump at his
funeral he's attacking Trump he he's
willing to have Barack Obama at his
funeral but not Donald Trump he's he's
releasing this memoir that's coming out
at the end of this month and in that
memoir he's throwing his former running
mate Sarah Palin under the bus this is I
don't want to attack John McCain am I
gonna spend time attacking John McCain
but I do want this to be a cautionary
tale because John McCain does this Palin
thing throwing Palin under the bus it
became so fashionable for all of the
sophisticated Republicans to attack
Sarah Palin oh she's a hick oh she's has
a silly accent oh she doesn't read
enough newspapers Oh blah blah blah
right and become very fashionable
especially when they lost
john mccain picked her now he can say
all they all wanted me to pick her and i
didn't want to pick her well the buck
stops somewhere pal and you john mccain
picked sarah palin she served him very
ably on the campaign she helped his
campaign people revisionists now say oh
she dragged that he might have won if
not for her no way his polling was in
the doldrums and then she came on and
she really helped his polling now now
John McCain is in his final days and he
decides to throw her under the bus he
makes one last jab at the sitting
Republican president and he throws his
former running mate under the bus this
is all in keeping with a trend among
Republicans to really want to win the
affection of the new york times
Republicans should never try to win the
affection of the New York Times do not
do it
this is the swamp mentality this is what
happens when Republicans come to
identify more with their pseudo
sophisticate Democrat critics than they
do with their own constituents and they
don't dance with the guy who brung them
you know the the Republican candidates
get elected because of conservatives
because of their base and then the
minute they get to Washington they say
oh I don't want to be with those people
those people are dirty in there then
they they don't read the Atlantic or
whatever so I please a New York Times
like me like me I'm not like them this
is a particular political disloyalty by
the way that history does not look
fondly upon everyone thinks in the
moment they say oh I can't oh I don't
like the Tea Party because they're too
direct and they speak too plainly and
they like the Constitution too much oh
no I'm not like them I go I drink
Manhattan's I drink no I read the
Atlantic who are these who are the
political disloyal people who don't like
their own base Mayor John Lindsay of New
York does history remember him is he one
of the great men oh yes John as John
Lindsay said you see epitaphs everywhere
big statues too always judges the great
John Lindsay said like Nelson
Rockefeller as the wonderful political
leader Nelson Rock no you don't you
forget these people they're not the
great leaders of the Republican Party or
any movement it's a weak sauce it's
really weak sauce you will never as a
conservative or as a Republican win the
affection of the newer times you'll win
it for a moment when it's instrumental
and it's useful and then they'll stab
you in the back as they did to John
McCain in two
thousand eight they were really really
nice to him during the primary they were
really really nice drum when he was
attacking George Bush in 2000 and when
he was attacking other conservatives in
2008 and then he gets the nomination
they go right back to their guy and they
attacked John McCain happens every time
they they they they will not reward you
betraying your base or the confidence of
your base
it looks desperate don't do it a
cautionary tale okay we'll get to more
we're at a time we'll get to more news
tomorrow in the meantime I am Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolan is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
borne senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018